je termine avec ceux ci qu est ce si
c'est un attelage une boule d'attelage
et là pour la démonter faut prendre des
outils faut prendre toutes sortes de
choses et c'est extrêmement pénible
chatterie remarque du tout alors vous
avez un numéro de téléphone 36,15 god
fr3 pour les idées mal placées dès que
vous voyez quelque chose comme ça
maintenant ça devient c'est un arrosoir
que tu peut étendre rapetisser tourner
dans tous les sens donc tu peux accéder
dans tous les sens at-on faute fleurs tu
vois tu te tournes comme ça pour que ça
se ressent beaucoup plus facilement
c'est bien là tu ne bouge pas c'est
parfait comme plan jean pierre et là ça
t'évite de renverser et il ya une
poignée qui te permet de tenir vraiment
très bien
salma dont une est lourd parce qu'il est
plein mais c'est vraiment c'est la
nature mais c'est tout à fait logique
moi j'aime beaucoup c'est très beau il
est très bon on s'était dit ça serait
bien de pouvoir la démonter cette doute
parce qu'on s'en sert pas sultan et
l'intérêt c'est pour l'instant vous ne
pouviez pas le faire en toute conscience
et en général que deux trois fois par an
mal an maintenant c'est possible
il ya aussi un petit système avec une
clé qui vous permet de la clique c'est
sans aucun problème
alors qu'il faut savoir c'est que c'est
pas commercialisé encore tu es le seul
inconvénient c'est qu'il faut quand même
avoir le système d'attaché normal quand
j'ai fait mouche